هو اضطراب يسبب
نوبات الصداع أولئك الذين يعانون من الصداع النصفي يعانون من
صداع متكرر يمكن أن يستمر من 4
إلى 72 ساعة ،
وعادة ما يكون الألم النابض أو الخفقان من جانب واحد متوسطًا
إلى شديد ويمكن أن يعطل الحياة اليومية ،
ولا يجب أن تعاني من توم
ديابيرتون  يقول مع مؤسسة الصداع الوطنية
أن العديد من المصابين بالصداع النصفي
قد يترددون في زيارة الطبيب ، لكنه
يقول إن مقدمي الرعاية الأولية يمكن أن يساعدوك في وضعك
على الطريق الصحيح لعلاج أو منع
نوبات
الصداع النصفي يمكن أن تحدث بسبب العديد من
المحفزات المختلفة ، يمكن أن تكون
حساسية تجاه الضوء  يمكن أن يكون نظامًا غذائيًا ، يمكن أن يكون
مجرد تغيير في
جدولك المعتاد ، يقول دابيرتون إن الاحتفاظ
بسجل للأطعمة التي تناولتها قبل نوبة الصداع النصفي ،
ثم إزالة هذه الأطعمة من
نظامك الغذائي قد يساعد في تحديد
المحفزات الغذائية المحتملة مع الاحتفاظ بمذكرات الصداع.
إعطائك فكرة عما
قد يثير هجومًا ، فقد يساعد أيضًا
طبيبك في تحديد العلاج
المناسب لك لتكون مستعدًا عندما تذهب
لرؤية  يتحدث الطبيب عن
الأعراض ويوثق ما يحدث
لأن
هذا الطبيب أو أن ذلك الممارس
جيد فقط مثل المعلومات التي
تقدمها لهم للحظة الصحية التي أحتاجها